(upbeat music)
- All right!
Yes, band!
Give it up for y'all!
(audience cheering)
Welcome back, y'all,
We are almost out of time,
but let's share one more positive story
from the world of social media.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
A mother in Minnesota is
spreading joy online, all
while fighting the
toughest fight of her life.
This is Stephanie who is
battling breast cancer.
Despite her diagnosis, she is
not letting it get her down.
So Stephanie creates dance videos
at each of her chemo appointments.
Not only is it helping her,
but it's inspiring thousands
online, which is incredible.
Her story was even featured
on her local afternoon
show, Twin Cities Live
on KSTP-TV in the Twin Cities.
Let's get her in here, everybody.
What's up, Stephanie?
(audience cheering)
So what inspired you to do this?
- Well, during chemo it takes about four
to five hours per session,
and I got really bored.
So I would scroll through
TikTok and find these dances
and think to myself, "I can do that."
So I just started doing
these TikTok dances
to pass the time.
But then it became bigger than me
and, it became something that
I just had to continue to do.
- Oh, my God, you're so good.
So where are you in your
treatment right now?
You're so good at dancing, oh, my gosh.
(Stephanie chuckling)
- Right now, I'm still
continuing my chemotherapy.
I've got about 53 chemos
under my belt since 2020.
My scans are looking good,
so we're just gonna continue the fight
until they tell me I
don't need to anymore.
- Amen.
(audience applauding)
Well, we are truly hoping for
the best for you, Stephanie.
All right, I'm liking your
posts right now, keep dancing.
(audience cheering)
- [Stephanie] Thank you, absolutely.
- And that's not all,
our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2, the go-to pen
on the Kelly Clarkson Show, wants
to honor truly unstoppable
people like yourself, ma'am.
So they're gonna write
you check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- [Stephanie] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Aww, I wish I could hug you right now.
(audience cheering)
Stephanie, God bless you, girl!
All right, thank you so much.
And thank you
to all our guests, Michelle Rodriguez.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly faintly speaking)
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.